What has been another disappointing day for the conservatives
after Thursday's local elections.
Let's take a look at the results,
most of which are now in. First the English mayoral races.
And in the last few hours
Labour mayors have been reelected in London,
Manchester, Salford, Liverpool,
South Yorkshire and West Yorkshire.
Still outstanding the West Midlands,
which Andy Street is hoping to hold on to for the Tories.
With just one of the hundred and seven English councils yet to declare,
Labour has gained eight councils overall
while the conservatives have lost ten
and now hold only half as many as the Liberal Democrats
who've gained two. There's no change for the greens and one fewer.
With no overall control.
More than two and a half thousand council seats were up for grabs.
Of these, Labour has gained 195
with the conservatives losing a massive 4 hundred and seventy three.
The Lib Dems gained 104, the Greens 74.
There are 93 more independents and Reform UK has won two council seats.
Results have also been declared in 35
of the 37 police and Crime commissioner contest
in England and Wales. Labour has flipped 10 from the conservatives
while Plaid Cumry held onto theirs.